big alarm bills big alarm bills and
Andrew always says Islam is intolerant
Islam is intolerant be ready for the
intolerance this is the intolerance that
we're showing you now you biged up Islam
for his intolerance this is the Muslims
are showing you the intolerance so
Andrew I know you're going to watch this
video I know you're going to watch the
video by the way do you not think I'm
going to die one day all this fun and
this if you genuinely believed like I'm
not saying you don't have a belief in
Islam but like Allah says in the Quran
to the bed you've become a Muslim don't
say im is ENT your he yet you'd have
time to get I have no fancy clothes
they're all gone now don't
realize you're not even fasting in
Ramadan do the basics bro at least if
you're going to do that at least hide it
you're publicly doing it Islam this
Islam is this this is beautiful d d d da
when you came out of prison m there was
physically humility with you but now
you've decided not to follow up and
you've you you going all the way back
it's Ramadan well it shows you also that
it's like when you needed Allah and your
were he was there but as soon as you
came this the ayat in the Quran when
they stranded in in the sea they say oh
God please deliver us to the the shore
and then when Allah delivers them on the
shore they go back to what they were
doing it's Ramadan and I'm not even
trying to be the Haram police here but
it's Ramadan and I'm the Haram police
and you in the club
yeah brothers and sisters and dear
friends while you guys are watching this
video we are in a competition with our
charity brothers and sisters in the next
one hour when this video is out we need
to the most we raise inallah to help
teach people how to play Salah you saw
the ad there inah yeah the sponsored ad
we will win a $5,000 prize so if you're
watching this guys if you can donate
whatever amount you can you can help us
to win an extra £5,000 we'll help teach
500 to £1,500 people to learn how to pay
Salah let's get straight into the video
in brothers and sisters and dear friends
I'm here with my close close brother
alhamdulillah who have known since I've
come to Islam D Loa um this is very
interesting because I've been thinking
about this for past couple of days um is
Andre take fasting now obviously I
didn't want to be like go let me go and
look in the internet Etc yeah sure sure
you found a video you sent it to me and
he was like bro look look what's going
on here and I was like I was thinking
about this a couple of days ago is this
guy even fasting bro at least now we're
going to come to good assumptions bad
assumptions in a minute but let's wor so
this they're in Florida in Miami in hisc
cousin's house cousin house let's watch
this in because this is a big alarm
bills big alarm bills and Andrew always
says Islam is intolerant Islam is
intolerant be ready for the intolerance
this is the intolerance that we're
showing you now you biged up Islam for
his intolerance this is the Muslims are
showing you the intolerance that we have
to people who seem like they use in
Islam I'm not saying you're not a Muslim
you you can be 100% but you are misusing
it you are misusing it sadly and you
you're careless about it how about that
yeah let's watch it in here we
go we're back we're
back yeah [__] H crazy you think in
two and a half years youd have time to
get a [__] space I have no fancy
clothes they're all gone now don't
realize become few pieces of clothes we
made you buy years [__] hell crazy
you think it's two and a half years
you'd have time to get SP no I have no
fancy clothes they're all gone now don't
realize how boring i' become two pieces
of clothes you made you wi gone first
thing what do you
notice well the first thing that I
noticed is there a like a lot swearing
already yeah you know and uh he has
something in his hands there he drinking
something yeah he's clearly drinking
something yeah and it's daytime we can
see it's daytime this video is current
he was in Florida so it's he he flew
there what a couple of days ago yeah
that's correct so from what we can see
cuz said we used to judge people based
on Revelation yeah Revelation St we
judge from was app parent app parent
yeah and right now we see you drinking
but let's carry on they we are totally
back you don't
understand now there's a lot of vogar
language yeah you can say for some
people it takes quite a bit of time to
get rid of it slowly sure but the thing
is the prophet said to us that Allah is
not need of the one to abstain from
water and drink if you cannot Vogal
language slandering
backbiting Allah is not need food food
and water I lot people were even people
talking about Islam and Muslims are oh
they just skipping lunch Lun skipping
lunch yeah yeah
to us fasting is not just abstain from
food and water that's why the prophet
said Allah is not neither for you
abstaining going through the hardship of
starving yourself when spiritually
you're not cleansing yourself and I mean
it's crazy it's crazy I
mean control is it it's also about
self-control CU if if you're controlling
yourself what goes into your belly you
to control what comes out of your mouth
that's why the pro tells us that if
you're not married fast if you canot
control what you eat you cannot control
your desires millions of dollars but
then I just realiz people on the
internet don't like me [__] that guy at
home with no money whose wife tells him
what to do doesn't like
me this as quite fake let me tell you
why cuz he's like oh that's that guy who
his wife doesn't what to do um I make
100 million Etc his Yar stick of success
is so whooped it's that he's basically
saying money oh look at me I have
hundred million okay one second if that
doesn't bother you why you even mention
it yeah don't you think so yeah why are
you talking about like if for example if
something you say doesn't bother me I
don't need to mention and say why the
says this but it doesn't bother me so my
life I don't want to talk about it the
fact that he mentions a poor man he
always has this yeah he belittles them
like this poor guy Etc I mean my let me
be honest with you a man in Islam a man
who earns a Halal income who may be poor
yeah we're not talking about a man who's
under the fit of his wife yes with all
du respect in Islam we alhamdulillah a
man should be like a man and this
doesn't mean you don't take true
masculinity yes true masculinity yeah
and this doesn't mean you oppress Your
Wife by the way I'm not saying that cor
man is the one who's the leader he has
Mercy on his wife do you get what I'm
trying to say so he's got this W idea
and he goes it seems like it bothers him
a lot actually for him to land in
Florida go to his cousin house see his
swimming pool and automatically measure
it by success and money and it seems
like it bothers you yeah I believe this
video I'm going to do is bother you but
we're showing you the intolerance of
Islam that you always loved
about now he has a cigar in his hand
yeah so there V language yeah he's not
fasting yeah and he's smoking and also
listen we're not saying don't enjoy
yourself oh yeah 100% right we not like
Party Poopers right we're not saying oh
Andrew listen brother like what you
doing don't you brothers are all so my
case kind of enjoy myself we're not
saying that we're saying you are aware
of your influence you say every single
time I'm so influential I'm promoting
masculinity I'm promoting uh strength
and youth but you know it's Ramadan W
all the Christians are talking about
Ramadan everyone is talking about
Ramadan everyone knows it's Ramadan and
yet you're out here recording this
because you're paying the people who are
recording this to make content and to
put out M so like there's clearly no
self-awareness here man like you make
you 100 million but like if you're
making 100 million and then you're only
self-aware when someone says to you
something yeah that bothers you but
you're not self-aware when it comes to
the morality that you used to pray so
much I'm very conf I don't believe this
is like this is how his lifestyle is
I'll be honest with you bro like w I'll
be honest with you like I've I've been
to places like I've been to like aldah
like I've saved my money and you know
taking my family out to holidays to
certain place ET when you book early you
get like you get good deals yeah and
I'll be honest with I've been the place
swimming pool and this that Al Allah has
given the ability to do this you know
and I'll be honest with you sometimes I
go down I go this is so boring W bro the
swimming gets boring the chilling gets
boring sometimes I go on holiday bro and
I'm actually like you know just go back
to London just just I'm just with my
family bro and I know it's fake bro I
can easy come and say guys I'm doing I
can W I can so easily bro so easily put
the whole Shang on and W bro I can make
my lifestyle look like his but I know
it's fake bro genuinely I know when I'm
there in the pool swimming up people my
family Etc I'm seeing that and I go well
I'm like I want to do some work I'm
bored like I want to be back doing some
Salah projects doing this or doing that
helping you with the pack I just want
that's me I just love doing that I see
this as fake yeah yeah and also you know
what it is it's
um these videos are designed for a
particular purpose yes they're shorten
away yes where they portray Andrew Tay
in a particular way and fair enough we
do it to to a certain extent but what
he's doing is he's selling a lifestyle
this speically telling people Hey listen
it does not matter what is happening to
me or what the Matrix is trying to do to
me yeah I am still wealthy
I'm still enjoying myself and these
people can't get to me and but that's
he's so poor that only thing he has his
money of course of so sad because if you
think about he doesn't come and say I
have a relationship with God like look
at sneo when I say alhamdulillah when I
this that about Islam being one this bro
he talks about the spiritual richness
yeah all he talks about is money this
that the guy and sne to be fair is quite
wealthy himself exactly he's quite
wealthy himself you see how he is Rich
internally but he's just Rich externally
yeah that's why I talk out it well let's
carry on sitting here eating this
tomahawk in Miami or so you think Luke
I'm still in jail so it's Tristan all AI
this has been the real world students
who went to the AI campus and said let's
fool Luke so they build an AI reality
head said those videos are designed to
promote him promote his brother promote
the uh the real world University that's
really what it is it is and you know
something really profound he goes it
looks like I'm eating Ste that I'm
actually in a prison so Prof you know
what that means he's basically saying
yeah I'm having all this fun Etc but I'm
actually like I've still got this thing
on my head of course do you know what
about that said visit the graves yet
it's the what it the destroyer of all
pleasures yeah death yeah it's the same
thing about that you can have all this
enjoyment but you know in the back of
your head I'm going to die one day yeah
it's luring no matter what how fun you
are I'm going to die one day he's
talking about prison I take that as I'm
going to die die one day so Andrew I
know you're going to watch this video I
know you're going to watch this video by
the way do you not think I'm going to
die one day all this fun and this if you
genuinely believed like I'm not saying
you don't have a belief in Islam but
like Allah says in the Quran to the beds
you've become a Muslim don't say im is
Iman hasn't ENT your heart bro with all
you respect it hasn't you're not even
fasting in Ramadan do the basics bro at
least if you're going to do that at
least hide it you're publicly doing it
so let's see if there's anything else
interesting and also what's very
interesting just before we go to the
next point because this video is getting
very very interesting yeah the problem
is that separately on different
platforms Andrew Tate is talking about
the pressure that he's feeling yeah so
what do you do psychologically you know
when you feel pressure you start dancing
when you feel pressure you go out when
you feel pressure you buy things when
you feel pressure you you you basically
put your uh self physically in a
position that is contrary to how
psychologically you think about the
whole scenario because we will see that
when it came to Miami yeah he didn't
really know what to expect yeah things
change as he as longer he stay he he
just going to get away with it but
they're trying to put Char yeah and we
talk about this more in detail if
there's else why we're staying home 3
years I haven't seen you Luke and I
thought you'd at least have enough
excitement in you to kind of want to
maybe go one place no why we're all here
together we've got each other
here problem solved I'm not going to lie
he seems very uncomfortable what saying
have no
language he's like he's very
disappointed cuz you know why cuz that's
the reality luk is leaving the reality
he's like bro I don't do this party like
because you know why it becomes boring I
know I came from that lifestyle it
becomes boring bro at the age of 20 21 I
was like this is boring what the hell is
this same pattern every week this might
going to be my life bro what the hell is
this Luke is it LCA what's his name Luke
yeah Luke he's like bro I don't want to
go anywhere yeah I want and he's like n
you know why CU that shows bro Luke
seems at least a bit more content in his
own space I'm happy here he's that nah
bro I need to go out I need to do
something you know what that shows
you're running from your Sorrows that's
the exactly bro and you know what's so
so powerful yeah is that if you sequence
this with what they were doing in the
pool yeah for Luke at least I'm not
going to speak for the man but it seems
like he's just happy of catching up
having a family moment again after such
a long time exctly that's what means him
something right and for him you can
really like you said you can see that
there stress building him because he's
saying bro the Romanian government and
every government in the world is telling
me to stay at home yeah so now that I'm
in America I want to yeah so it shows
you that Andrew Tate still hasn't
updated his operating system he's still
in the operating system of like going
out party this that that people looking
at me means I'm valid validation and
projection strength and power so he
hasn't really changed this aspect of J
un there's still great weakness in that
because if one needs to do that it shows
great weakness yeah coffee before bed
out your
mind you are I'm happy to be reunited
with Andrew's
cousin no should okay I should be home
and 10 americanos we're jet lagged thank
you 10 and 10 look do you have admit
this for going out we go out the best
way car drives US security I will admit
that I will admit that yes it's kind of
moving home I'll bet I tried to make him
into a me and tried to make him into a
him and he decided to become nobody at
all Mr
ghost trist ghost like I'm trying to
make him to be like me he's trying to
make me meaning they're trying to
influence each other what to do Luke is
saying guys look I'm old now I don't do
this no more you know this more of an
adult than they yeah yeah they still
children and there's a lot of videos
about this Luke brother as well uh that
he sort of is the brain child of the
Hustler University he's a very very
intelligent guy I mean all of them are
very intelligent but he precisely very
more collected and more like in the
shadows you know and you see it well if
if Luke you can see he's a hardw
workking man like yeah Luke if you come
to Islam may Allah may Allah guide you
to Islam because you have your very
beautiful traits already you're showing
traits of a Muslim who's like look I
don't want to have to go out I don't
have to do this clubbing I'm fine in my
own I'm contented in my own house Subhan
Allah you know may Allah guide him may
Allah guide him to Islam and um lastly
they end their Ramadan celebrations with
the
following yeah I mean that's it guys you
know you can see Subhan Allah I'll be
honest with you he's on his way down
he's on his way down with a lot of
aspects and to be honest with you if
there was anything that could have
helped him um to become the better
version of himself become a better man
with Islam and it seems like he's not
taking advantage of that because you
know why he's too focused on the Dy he
believes the success is this that's why
you can see he doesn't have people of
Muslims around him he doesn't have these
people around him he doesn't keep them
he doesn't have people of knowledge
doesn't gain knowledge he hasn't go to
the holy lands he's like there's nothing
you can see in him like and and that's
why we give the comparison sneo because
noo you can see his
thing and this me like 2 and a half
years he being a Muslim yeah and I'll be
honest with you bro it's starting to
become a label it's just like Oh I'm a
Muslim he keeps using this I'm a Muslim
I don't buy it and this is Andrew Tate's
Ramadan for you and to be fair to be
fair to be a bit more contextual he's
been under house arrest for a very long
time but it doesn't mean that you can't
invite people of of good quality to your
house yeah yeah well like I remember
yeah and this is a randomly this is like
year last year I was watching another
Vlog of their and it was in Romania same
thing they're going to the beach and
they going to clubs and blah blah blah
and one of Tristan's Friends start
vomiting like this well I proper and all
you see you see Andrew yeah in the car
he sits like this and he looks at disuss
he's like w this is disgusting you can
tell he knows that this isn't the way he
knows it
but the pressure that he's experiencing
from the governments internationally
trying to put him into prison and trying
to get him
yeah brother Andrew this is not the
solution this is not the solution this
is not in fact now he went to Miami yeah
the governor in Miami who has like some
political issues with Trump yeah is now
using him to get get to Trump and they
open up a
persecution and Andrew T has to go back
to Romania as well so brother Andrew
look if things are not getting easier
well this is a principle in Islam Okay
the reason why you go through
tribulations is one because Allah wants
to get you closer to him and there's two
reasons why Allah wants to get you
closer to him either it's because of
your sins and that's a mercy that Allah
is making life harder so that your soul
turns back to Allah
yeah if that is not the case is these
things are happening because you're not
changing Allah says in the Quran if you
do not change your situation then Allah
will not change your situation Allah
will not change the condition of man
until he Chang us within himself well is
this whole Matrix Trump yeah W these W
he have six because he's talking about
Trump W he have 100 trumps supporting
you taking to look Trump did he not take
you to America he took you to America
look even in his own country he wasn't
able to protect you yeah exactly exactly
and not only that Allah says in the Quan
there's a verse I can paraphrase but in
a n Allah subh says that we send them
signs and
signs and until they carry on their
transgression and they they they
basically think that they are un
then Allah says we open the doors to
what they want and when they think they
are at the top we seize them suddenly
say we suddenly sees them yeah and we
ask Allah to protect you from that
that's me last sorry sorry last last
thing I wanted to say cuz I'm very
passionate about this yeah
look brother
Andrew W there's other celebrities who
are Muslim they don't say they're Muslim
you know why cuz they say look I can't
say I'm a Muslim because my lifestyle
doesn't go hand and we know personally
Brothers c big big big celebrities
they're Muslims but they don't say it
because they're like look my lifestyle
doesn't line yeah the problem because
you said a couple months ago yo this is
not your dad's religion I agree this
religion doesn't belong to us but you
know what this you know this religion is
protected by its people yes and it's
been protected by its people for 1,400
years the Quran has been protected by
the souls Souls of the Muslims and the
religion and the way it's been practiced
is protected by the people too so it's
you who put yourself out there on the
platform you said about Islam this Islam
is this this is beautiful da d d da when
he came out of prison Mah there was
physically humility with you but now
you've decided not to follow up and
you've you you going all the way back
it's Ramadan but it shows you also that
it's like when you needed Allah and your
he was there but as soon as came out the
ayat in the Quran when they stranded in
in a sea they say oh God please uh
deliver us to the the shore and then
when Allah delivers them on the shore
they go back to what they were doing
it's Ramadan and I'm not even trying to
be the Haram police here but it's
Ramadan and I am I'm the Haram police
and you're in the club yeah subh what
can we say sisters we're going to leave
it to you inshallah guys till next time